[Music]
code reusability is one of the most
important concepts in all of software
development but what often happens is
you write some code in one app and then
you want to reuse it in a different app
down the road maybe you're back at cloud
functions or a different front-end app
but it's not very easy to reuse that
code because it's tightly coupled to one
specific app in today's video we'll look
at code sharing strategies specifically
for large JavaScript projects if you're
new the channel like and subscribe and
grab the full source code from angular
firebase.com and i'm also giving away
some free swag with this video all you
have to do is leave a comment below and
I'll randomly pick a winner by this
weekend let's imagine that we have three
different apps we have a customer facing
angular app we used view to build an
admin app and then we have a cloud
functions back-end with note j s our
goal with this video is to orchestrate
all these projects with firebase and
then also share common business logic
and typescript interfaces between them
so I just have an empty directory opened
up here in vs code and the first thing
I'll do is generate our angular
front-end by running the ng new command
this just generates a basic angular app
but the important thing to keep in mind
here is that this project has its own
package.json and it also has its own
dedicated git repository now to add some
complexity I'll also generate a view app
with the view CLI and just like angular
it has its own package JSON and its own
git repo then we'll give our app a
back-end by initializing firebase and
I'm going to select functions and
hosting as the firebase features the
functions directory is also a node.js
project so it has its own package JSON
and then it doesn't have a git
repository by default but you can
initialize one in there as well so now
we have firebase initialized in this
parent directory and we can orchestrate
the deployments for our front-end apps
and our functions I have an entire video
on multi site hosting so make sure to
check that out but what we can do in
this firebase JSON file is set up
multiple hosting targets so we can
deploy our angular app to one URL and
our view app to a different URL but have
them share the same firebase project at
this point we have a project with
multiple apps and we have a big decision
to make do we structure this as a mono
repo or maintain multiple repos first
let's look at mono repo Xand
to decide if that would be a good
decision or not to make this a mono repo
we would first remove the git
repositories in the individual apps and
then set up a single git repo in the
root of this project this means that any
time code is committed it's immediately
synchronized to all apps within the
project and it gives you a single
centralized place to manage all pull
requests and issues that come up a
perfect example of a mono repo is
angular itself for example you have
dozens of different projects within the
angular mono repo such as the router
reactive forms etc all these packages
share the same versioning so there's
never any question about whether or not
you're using the right package so if you
have a project that has many different
developers contributing or has many
different sub projects nested under it I
would highly recommend going the mono
repo approach and there's some good
tools out there to help you get the job
done right there's a package called
lerna which is used by the firebase SDK
and many other JavaScript projects and
there's also an X from Narwhal which is
an awesome tool for creating mono repos
with angular
but mono repos aren't the right choice
for every project they also have their
downsides a pretty big drawback is a
loss and flexibility it's a lot easier
to test and deploy an individual repo
than it is to deploy and test an entire
mono repo and when you have small
focused projects you're free to work on
them with whatever tooling and best
practices that you established that
level of flexibility tends to be very
beneficial to small teams and
individuals where it might add chaos if
you're a large enterprise team with a
hundred developers because I'm an
independent developer and only have a
few projects nested within this
workspace I'm going to go with the multi
repo approach now let's look at how we
can reuse code between these projects by
using a shared library with NPM I'm
gonna go ahead and create another
directory here called shared stuff and
then we'll see the end of that directory
and run NPM init to start a new package
from scratch the purpose of this library
is to share code between our projects by
being installed as a dependency in
whatever app needs to use it the first
thing I'll do is create an indexed es
file inside of here and if we look in
the package JSON you'll notice that it
has a main property that points to index
j s that's just the main entry point for
this package then we also want to share
Taipings in this project so I'm going to
set up the types property and have that
point to index
DTS typescript will generate these files
for us automatically when we build our
code here in a minute a really common
use case is to share interfaces between
projects so I might have a user
interface that I want to use in my
angular app my admin app and also in my
cloud functions if I were to clear this
interface in my angular front-end for
example I wouldn't be able to import it
anywhere else but in a shared package we
can use it in any other JavaScript
project then we can also export business
logic here as well so I'll just create a
function called create ID that returns a
random string so now we need to package
our library so it can be consumed by
other projects for a simple use case
like this we can just use typescript
directly but for more complex libraries
you'll probably want to use something
like roll-up to build our library we
need a build script so we'll go into the
package JSON and the build command is
just TSC index TS and then flag d2 also
include the type beans now we can just
run npm run build from the command line
and that will package up everything with
our index j s and Taipings now we're
ready to put our shared library to use
if your company has a lot of shared
packages I would recommend getting an
NPM organization set up so you can
install everything remotely but for now
we'll just go ahead and install our
shared library locally
we'll start by seeding into our angular
front-end and then we'll run NPM install
with the path to the folder that
contains the shared stuff then if we
open our package JSON in the angular app
you'll see that we now have a dependency
of the shared stuff library and we can
start using it just like we would with
any other NPM package for example I'll
go into the app component here then I'll
import that Creed ID function that we
wrote inside of the library then we'll
use it to replace the title property on
the app component then when we serve the
app it generates the title as expected
now we can go into our view app or our
functions and follow the exact same
process and get the exact same results
obviously this is a lot more reliable
than trying to copy and paste code
between projects but it can also really
help with tooling especially when you
have shared interfaces all I have to do
is start typing the interface and BS
code will know to auto import it and
we'll also get the intellisense
autocomplete for all of our shared code
so that's how you create a shared
JavaScript library for your project
it can get a lot more complex from there
with packaging and things like that but
the final thing that we want to consider
here is that we have this root project
directory but it's currently not under
source control the content in this
directory is just configuration stuff so
the firebase CLI knows where to deploy
our apps but you probably want it under
version control as well so we'll
initialize a git repository here then
we'll say get add and git commit when
you create a git repository that has
other git repositories nested inside of
it the child repositories will be
treated as sub modules I'm going to go
ahead and push this code to github and
if we look at the sub module as you can
see that they're just grayed out folders
and we can't actually click inside of
them in this context we're just using
the sub modules as placeholders to show
what our actual project structure looks
like in other contexts they can be a
pain to deal with
but with our multi repo approach we're
managing each one individually so they
can be thought of as their own separate
projects I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there hopefully this video
helped you understand how to share code
between large JavaScript and/or firebase
projects if you have any questions leave
me a comment below and if you want to
learn about more advanced concepts
consider upgrading to a pro membership
at angular firebase com you'll get
access to my full courses and a whole
bunch of other exclusive content thanks
for watching and I'll talk to you soon